[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'avais proposé une trentaine de
sujets qui étaient presque toutes mes
doigts ce sujet qu'elle voulait aborder
en interdiction des ports de saint
brieuc la fonction publique dire est que
la plupart de mes élèves vont être en
mode je m'en fous un peu
en faisant un petit peu leur terme dans
ce sens pour eux c'est très loin de la
réalité de tous les jours
qui est pour le projet de loi sur la
laïcité qui est contre le projet de loi
je crois que c'est contre parce que je
crois que le cidre les yeux n'a aucune
influence sur la pensée de la personne
fut pauvre parce que selon moi ne pas se
faire imposer une religion c'est comme
une mode c'est ta religion tu sais que
tu es dans ta religion donc de
connaissez vraiment besoin de nous
l'imposer quelqu'un elle pourrait porter
un signe religieux mais être neutre dans
ce qu'elle va dire pense qu'elle va
comment il va se comporter avec les
autres personnes elle pourrait ne
portait aucun signe religieux et avoir
des idées des idées extrémistes ou ne
pas représenter parfaitement un état
laïc
je veux rappeler c'est comme aller
professeur qui on peut vraiment le droit
de dire mettons leur opinion par rapport
à la religion et donc les personnes qui
sont en position de tête et je vois pas
pourquoi qui auraient droit nous
exprimer leur religion de façon plus et
externe par exemple - qui portent pas
personnellement de signes religieux mais
je me sens atteindre par cette loi parce
que personnellement j'ai aussi mes amis
qui veulent par exemple devenir
professeurs ou enseignants et qui
peuvent pas faire leur rêve dans
l'avenir à cause de cela
moi ça me c'est justement beaucoup de
tristesse à cause de ça ceux qui disent
moi je veux refusé de l'enlever peu
importe la loi qu'est ce que ça vous
dise la personne que je vois passer
maintenant une policière avec son voile
ben moi même ça a passé avec c'est comme
si à passer avec un chapeau - cap force
avec n'importe quoi et ça me fait rien
je pense que c'est vraiment de l'abus
parce qu'il ya des gens qui portent des
signes religieuse c'est vraiment eu ça
fait vraiment partie depuis s'inscrivent
fort difficile qu'ils changent
moi je mange pas de viande mais ça fait
partie de ma personnalité à moi parce
que j'ai des valeurs pour ce donc la
personne qui porte son voile parce qu'il
est musulman baisse a rejoint ses
valeurs les valeurs ça fait partie de
notre personnel quand c'est déjà en
position d'autorité le je trouve que
c'est important que ce soit neutre mais
faut pas non plus dire que en public on
peut juste pas sur l'eau oui parce que
si un jeune enfant voit son professeur
avec son voile peut-être qu'il veut dire
ah ben moi je dois être comme mon
professeur et je dois peut-être dessus
religion là où je dois faire la même
chose au jeu sort genre du rejet le fait
de refuser de porter quelque chose qui
n'a pas vraiment nécessaire moins
d'affluence sur nos décisions jour
georges parce que vraiment diriger je me
sens réalité qu'est ce que plusieurs
personnes qui sentent rejetés ici parce
je ne sens pas acceptée comme je suis
tel que je suis avec mon signes
religieux par exemple avec ma façon de
m'habiller ou et peu importe si on n'en
voit pas beaucoup fait que c'est un peu
dur de se faire une idée parce que c'est
juste comme un sujet un peu abstrait
j'ai vraiment l'impression que c'est un
problème intergénérationnel parce que je
vois mes grands-parents qui est même
encore mes parents un peu comme c'est
surtout un qui veut et qui sont pour la
laïcité est ce que vous trouvez que les
québécois sont racistes
ça serait mauvais dire ça j'ai même
question de choses c'est ancré dans la
culture québécoise qui depuis des
centaines d'années on on essaie de
racheter les personnes qui sont
différentes je pense que c'est de
l'ignorance de la part de certains
québécois parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu le
côtoyer nous en tant que communauté et
non pas pu savoir à quel point nous
étions par rapport à notre religion
on peut pas généraliser par exemple peut
pas dire les québécois sont racistes
parler des gens racistes ça existe
partout dans le monde
lorsqu'il ya des arrivées massives de
migrants
je crois que ça fait souvent par la
population quand on regarde souvent nos
parents nous grands parents souvent
c'est vrai ils ont tendance à être plus
racisme on dirait que notre génération
est beaucoup plus ouverte
moi je le vois comme
une manière de pousser les gens à ne
plus limiter au québec est ce qu'il ya
des gens parmi vous qui êtes croyants
qui se considèrent athées ou agnostiques
ça veut dire que vous croyez que
peut-être quelque chose mais je pensais
pas que c'est dans les religions
donc ouais vous êtes athée lever la main
on n'aurait plus besoin que tout le
monde se comprennent tout le monde soit
d'accord
l'un l'autre tout le monde soit juste
avec tout le monde qui porte à turban
une croix peu importe la religion en
fait est juste nous comprendre être
juste en fait la société a beaucoup
évolué et puis avec aussi les la
communication qu'on a maintenant que
dans le temps où est ce que l'église
catholique avait une grosse emprise b
les jeunes du québec tête était moins
ouverte sur le monde puis maintenant
c'est différent pour avancer dans une
société avant l'ouverture d'esprit que
c'est la chose la plus importante
j'aime la différence rochefoucauld un
monde de paris je trouverai un peu plat
voudra finir aussi dans une situation
qu'on dit souvent dans mon pays en fait
la religion appartient à dieu et la
patrie appartient au peuple
le gouvernement ne devrait pas
intervenir dans la religion du paf
[Musique]